bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
suivez en direct sur tv fil 78 c'est
l'heure du journal de la rédaction le
7-8 lecture et il sera notamment
question ce soir des retards à la sncf
elle aligne ses perturber ces dernières
semaines en cause un système qui serait
trop sécurisées les explications à
suivre dans toutes les disciplines
il est souvent pris à partie voire même
violente et les 12ème journée de
l'arbitrage se déroule actuellement et
se termineront le 3 novembre nous
livrons un jeune arbitre sur le terrain
pour écouter l son témoignage halloween
c'est déjà ce soir vous avez sans doute
pensé pour costume mais avez vous
préparez vos citrouilles quelques
derniers conseils dans cette édition
avant de vous laisser envahir par la
peur l'image du jour c'est à la base de
loisirs à saint quentin en yvelines
pendant trois jours à trappes se
dérouler la 16e édition de l'opération
sport en fille un événement qui permet
de promouvoir le sport au féminin en ile
de france les filles représentent à
l'heure actuelle à peine 35 % des
licenciés des différents clubs
l opération se terminer donc aujourd'hui
jeudi sport en fille et chaque année
ouvert aux jeunes filles issues des
quartiers populaires d'île de france
au total près de 400 adolescents âgés de
12 à 17 ans ont découvert une quinzaine
d'activités comme le speed ball les
scream ou encore le karaté elles ont pu
aussi côtoyer des athlètes de haut
niveau une entrevue avec les filles
parce que les garçons quand ils sont là
ils gâchent il veut tout faire à eux et
le laisser dans les côtes et 12-13 ans
et on arrive à la phase où on quand on
pratique du sport depuis quand on est
petit on arrive à la phase où on
arrivait à les copains à l'école etc
donc c'est vraiment la phase on arrête
un petit peu le sport c'est vrai que
continuer c'est difficile je pense que
se développe de plus en plus parce que
je pense pas que ça fasse peur c'est
justement ça permet les filles disent
que ça va se permettre de se défendre
donc je pense que c'est c'est pas un
frein pour ça des retards qui se
multiplient ces dernières semaines a la
sncf les usagers de la ligne c doivent
composer avec ces désagréments permanent
comment s'explique cette situation voici
les précisions les réponses d'anthony
rech olivier maniscalco et jonathan
vilma c'est le lot quotidien de milliers
d'usagers sncf ces deux dernières
semaines entre paris le sud yvelinois
sur la ligne du rer c est lorsque l'on
arrive sur lequel le matin ou le soir
c'est souvent pour découvrir que son
train et retarder voire carrément
supprimés quelquefois on est bien
informé
quelquefois non pas du tout quelquefois
les informations sont inaudibles
quand le problème c'est qu'il ya passé
du coup de donna de navets toutes choses
qui sont mises en place pour remédier à
ce à quoi s'est vraiment je dois prendre
un train qui va la direction opposée
après le jeune démerder pour prendre des
trucs qui respecte pendant quelques
temps au niveau des horaires et pendant
trois quatre jours papy ne respectait
plus 50 est donc c'est vrai que c'est un
peu embêtant pour ceux qui travaillent
qu'en outre l'automne et ses feuilles
mortes qui retarde les trains c'est le
système de signalisation qui
perturberait essentiellement les rames
dès qu'une canette de soda ou même une
simple épingle se coince dans les rails
au mauvais endroit
la signalisation automatique sur
interprète les risques et oblige les
trains à stopper leur trajet
le système de sécurité de la sncf c'est
que lorsqu'il ya le moindre incident les
feux se mettent aux rouges et les trains
s'arrêtent et dans cette hypothèse bien
le mécanicien le conducteur du train est
obligé de demander à repartir et c'est
ça en fait qui peut créer des problèmes
de ponctualité
c'est une ligne qui est compliqué qu'il
ya beaucoup de pâtes et des incidents en
fait même mineurs peuvent se propager
d'une branche à une autre et c'est ça
qui la rend fragile en situation
perturbée depuis le drame de brétigny
sur orge la compagnie ferroviaire ne
souhaite prendre aucun risque en matière
de sécurité
en attendant l'amélioration du réseau
via les travaux qui s'opèrent chaque
nuit sur la ligne c la sncf ne promet
pas pour l'instant d'amélioration dans
les semaines à venir
on ouvre une page économie à présent
dans ce journal le crédit agricole se
prépare à s'installer dans un nouveau
bâtiment à guyancourt la première pierre
vous le savez a été posée la semaine
dernière nous en avions parlé l immeuble
de bureaux baptisé alsace prendra place
sur un campus déjà existant depuis 1978
à la direction qui ambitionne de créer
un pôle technologique car quand bien sur
le site du crédit agricole de guyancourt
les grues ont pris leur quartier les
ouvriers s'activent
un nouveau bâtiment devrait voir le jour
début 2015 créé à la fin des années 70
pour héberger les activités de
back-office le campus n'a cessé de
s'agrandir avec ce sixième bâtiment le
crédit agricole souhaite en faire son
pôle technologique majeure on a déjà une
bonne partie des populations qu'on va
qualifier entre guillemets de haïti qui
sont présentes ici sur le site
à terme en ramener permettra d'ailleurs
plus de collaboration entre l'ensemble
de cette composante c'est vraiment
l'animation d'une nuit métier systèmes
d'information qui sera basée pour leur
très grande majorité sur ce site et donc
c'est cette collaboration au sein de
cette ligne métier qui en sera
grandement facilité à terme plus de 1200
collaborateurs devraient rejoindre ce
campus dans le nouveau bâtiment baptisé
alsace on comptera cinq étages de
bureaux et 4 niveaux de parking son
architecture a été pensé avec les
ateliers 115 tout le travail sur la
façade a été très important parce que
il a fallu réfléchir à l'intégration
d'architecturés temps dans le cas du
campus globale où il ya déjà un certain
nombre de bâtiments un peu daté qui
existent déjà bon pour s'intégrer dans
ce campus
voilà qui est impressionnant et puis
aussi s'intégrer dans la ville c'est le
rôle des promoteurs aussi de faire
attention à l'intégration urbaine
puisque les bâtiments qu'on laisse
derrière nous on vivre dans le temps et
puis la dimension aussi bioclimatique de
la conception nos façades qui selon
leurs orientations va était aussi il est
extrêmement important
une meilleure protection et des dépenses
d'énergie limitée
après cette phase de construction les
deux premiers bâtiments du site seront
rénovés
ce projet ne s'achèvera donc qu'à la fin
2016 on y comptera alors 4500 salariés
il avait entamé leur grève de la faim le
18 septembre
cette salariée syndicaliste sud de psa
peugeot citroën à poissy ont finalement
décidé de mettre fin à leur action après
avoir obtenu un accord avec la direction
il dénonce un harcèlement moral une
discrimination syndicale une enquête de
l'inspection du travail sur les droits
syndicaux se ramener le paiement de la
quasi totalité des heures de grève ainsi
qu'une période de convalescence
rémunérés ont été assurés
le secrétaire de sud auto sur le site
annonce étudié aussi la possibilité de
déposer une plainte pour non assistance
à personne en danger contre le pdg de
psa philippe varin pour écouter la
réaction des syndicalistes eux rendez
vous sur fit l'écho le magazine
économique et de la rédaction à 18h30
19h30 et 23 heures ce jeudi soir cela
fait tout juste un mois le 1er octobre
kevin maladry a ouvert la première
mangathèque de versailles un concept
dérivé du japon que l'on trouvait déjà
dans les cafés manga à paris on peut
soit y acheter des mangas soit les
consulter sur place à 25 ans ce
passionné s'est lancé seul il espère
bien pouvoir encore développer son
magasin eolen thorez patrick jacques de
dixmude l'on rencontrait à 25 ans kevin
a décidé de conjuguer travail et passion
depuis tout petit l'univers des mangas
le fascine après ses études de commerce
et quelques années en tant que vendeur
multimédia pour avoir une petite
expérience du client il se lance seul et
crée la première mangathèque de
versailles le même concept que les cafés
monga mai
exister pour le moment qu'à paris le
principe est simple soit on achète son
manga 9 soit on lit un manga d'occasion
dans la salle de lecture
donc on a salle de lecture qui étaient
fournies par beaucoup de nos clients et
par moi-même puisque nous rachetons les
mangas d'occasions pour fournir en salle
de lecture pour permettre à tout le
monde de pouvoir lire c'est une sorte de
partage en fait que j'ai voulu faire
plutôt que de revendre des mangas
d'occasions comme le font certains
certains magasins c'est si vous pouvez
avec les clients justement des notamment
des nouveaux clients qui ne connaissent
pas les mangas leur faire apprendre à
apprécier justement la vraie valeur d'un
manga puis aujourd'hui ya beaucoup de
personnes c'est qu'ils restent bloqués
sur l'idée que le manga et gad jeu vidéo
mangal violence du coup à qui est pas
tellement apprécié des personnes âgées
notamment
mais voilà en commençant leur expliquer
un peu à leur dire comment ça fonctionne
et c'est ça qui me fait aussi plaisir
c'est que commence à apprécier le manga
et à comprendre surtout de comprendre en
fait l'attaqué des titans
aujourd'hui c'est un succès énorme donc
au japon c'est on n'avait pas vu un
succès comme ça depuis one piece naruto
c'est c'est vraiment un très très beau
scénario les dessins sont pas terribles
mais les scénarios est vraiment
excellent
l'avantagé manga c'est que on peut les
prendre un peu comme un scénario de film
ou du coup on va commencer à dire le
premier tome on va être enchaînés dans
une histoire dans un engrenage avoir des
mystères qui vont s'insérer ou même des
choses très comique où on se surprend à
rire tout seul alors qu'on est juste
dans un livre et c'est ça qui me plaît
en fait dans l'est dans les mangas on
peut même pleuré ça arrive et
c'est soi ce qui m'a plu dans les mangas
et c'est ce que je peux recommander à
tout le monde en fait ces histoires il
les connaît pratiquement tout
il a lu plus de 90% des mangas de sa
boutique
à terme il aimerait poursuivre
l'aventuré en y organisant des
événements soirées déguisées ou encore
tournoi de jeux vidéo il a déjà plein
d'idées derrière la tête fêtait
halloween sont citrouille c'est
forcément impensable à quelques heures
de cette fête des fantômes la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines a
proposé un atelier de confection de
citrouilles anthony rech patrick jacques
de dixmude s'y sont essayés avant
d'aller ce soir de porte en porte
réclamer des bonbons ou de jeter des
sorts cette trentaine de petits démons
est venu confectionner son jacquot
lanterne à la base de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
à chacun sa méthode pour faire de sa
citrouille un monstre effrayant
moi j'ai changé le grain j'ai fait un
chapeau à ma citrouille j'ai gratté
intérieures jai enlever les graines
après l'avoir lavée les enfants du vide
et les graines et les filaments de leurs
citrouilles avant de creuser la chair du
potiron malgré l'aide des parents le
résultat n'est pas toujours terrifiant
si ça ressemble ainsi que les filles 1
c'est une vraie citrouille oui ouais
hermine par titre aujourd'hui
cet atelier est aussi l'occasion de
faire découvrir aux enfants que la
citrouille n'est pas que le petit
monstre illuminé d'halloween suivant les
citrouilles certaines graines se venge
ou pas alors après je ne les connais pas
tout pour être très honnête je sais que
la graine du petit marrons grillés on
peut la manger un peu salée à l'apéritif
on sait très très bon on trouve
aujourd'hui des teints en graines de
potiron graine de p'tit marron et c'est
donc effectivement nous presque tout se
mange et pour le reste de la citrouille
les poules de la ferme sont chargeront
avec plaisir après avoir goûté à la
soupe
ces petits dés me pourrait peut-être
vous effrayer une fois la nuit tombée
et joyeux halloween forcément la suite
de ce journal sera consacrée aux
journées de l'arbitrage vous entendrez
le témoignage d'un jeune arbitre et qui
a vécu qui a rencontré des violences sur
le terrain lors d'un match mais déjà
retour sur l'actualité du jour avec ces
retards qui s'accumulent ces dernières
semaines à la sncf elle les usagers de
la ligne c qui doivent composer avec les
désagréments permanent comment
s'explique la situation la réponse avec
anthony rech olivier maniscalco et j'en
attends il
c'est le lot quotidien de milliers
d'usagers cncf ces deux dernières
semaines entre paris le sud yvelinois
sur la ligne du rer c est lorsque l'on
arrive sur le quai le matin ou le soir
c'est souvent pour découvrir que son
train et retarder voire carrément
supprimés quelquefois on est bien
informé quelquefois non pas du tout
quelquefois les informations sont
inaudibles trop le problème c'est qu'il
ya passé du coup de denat de navets
toutes choses qui sont mises en place
pour remédier à ce à quoi s'est vraiment
je dois prendre un train qui va
direction opposée à preuve d'un démerder
pour prendre des trucs
il respecte pendant quelques temps au
niveau des horaires et pendant trois
quatre jours papy ne respectait plus ça
en fait donc c'est vrai que c'est un peu
embêtant pour ceux qui travaillent quoi
outre l'automne et ses feuilles mortes
qui retarde les trains c'est le système
de signalisation qui perturberait
essentiellement les rames avec une
canette de soda ou même une simple
épingle se coince dans les rails au
mauvais endroit
la signalisation automatique sur
interprète les risques et oblige les
trains à stopper leur trajet le système
de sécurité de la sncf fait que
lorsqu'il y a le moindre incident les
feux se mettent aux rouges et les trains
s'arrêtent et
dans cette hypothèse bien le mécanicien
le conducteur du train est obligé de
demander à repartir et c'est ça en fait
qui peut créer des problèmes de
ponctualité
c'est une ligne qui est compliqué qu'il
ya beaucoup de pâtes et des incidents en
fait même mineurs peuvent se propager
d'une branche à une autre et c'est ça
qui la rend fragile en situation
perturbée depuis le drame de brétigny
sur orge la compagnie ferroviaire ne
souhaite prendre aucun risque en matière
de sécurité
en attendant l'amélioration du réseau
via les travaux qui s'opèrent chaque
nuit sur la ligne c la sncf ne promet
pas pour l'instant d'amélioration dans
les semaines à venir
jusqu'au 3 novembre se déroule les 12ème
journée de l'arbitrage elles permettent
de mettre en valeur le rôle de l'arbitré
sur les terrains de sport si souvent
critiqué dans le football actuel
notamment et nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de nicolas perron après avoir
été agressé sur le terrain ce jeune
arbitre yvelines aura continue pourtant
est d'exercer ce qu'il considère comme
une passion anthony rech a rencontré en
décembre 2009 sa carrière de mont noir
aurait pu basculer lors d'une rencontre
de u17 entre versailles et l'encours
nicholas perron accorde un but contre
l'avis d'un juge de touche bénévoles en
l'espace de quelques secondes le match
dégénère
toute l'équipe qui a pris le but vient
vers moi pour me mettre la pression à ce
niveau là où il y avait l'assistant donc
j'étais en train de m'expliquer que qui
avait pas hors jeu donc on accorder de
but et toute critique est venu pour
mettre la pression
j'ai vu le jour qui la concerne courir
après et donc à ce moment là j'ai
commencé à courir pour m'enfuir en
espérant que les dirigeants arrêtent les
joueurs nicolas est alors roué de coups
avant d'être protégé par son père
la police doit intervenir le jeune
arbitre de 19 ans dépose plainte et le
district des yvelines prononce notamment
20 ans de suspension et d'interdiction
de jouer pour deux joueurs de son côté
cet ancien arrière gauche a gagné son
propre match en continuant d'arbitré il
possède désormais le statut de jeune
arbitre de fédérations et dirige des
rencontres de -19 ans nationaux depuis
l'âge de 13 ans nicolas a pris sifflet à
la bouche a dirigé le jeu protéger les
acteurs mais surtout laisser vivre le
ballon
toute une batterie de compétences que
les journées de l'arbitrage mais
talonneur
les personnes qui regardent le match ne
voit pas quand l'arbitré quelque chose
de bien par exemple quand il ya
peut-être une petite faute qui laisse
l'avantagé et qu'au final il ya but
les gens ils vont me dire oh un
magnifique but mais bon personne va se
dire au départ de l'action
c'est larbi qu'après une bonne édition
tous les trois ans plus de la moitié des
vingt-sept mille hommes en noirs
recensés par la fédération française de
football abandonne le terrain avant de
recevoir dans un instant à un arbitre
justement sur ce plateau pour discuter
avec lui de ces journées nationales de
l'arbitrage et évoqué son témoignage je
vous propose de vous écouter vous donner
la parole à présent c'est notre question
du jour vous le savez chaque soir tout
au long du journal vous réagissez à
l'actualité aujourd'hui nous vous avons
demandé comment faire respecter les
arbitres sur un terrain de sport voici
vos réponses
il ya souvent des erreurs d'arbitrage
dans le sport notamment dans le foot et
c'est pour ça - pour moi il devrait
instaurer la vidéo et sinon en général à
part le foot l'arbitré générale est
plutôt bien son taf
si on prend des joueurs en dix arbitres
c'est que ça y'a plus de respect
kim en ajournant le sport et j'en serai
moins agressif jouer pour le jeu et pas
pour l'argent vous éduquer les joueurs
dès l'entraînement des fûts jeune âge
pour moi voilà mais il commence
l'entraînement dans un club pro bas
falloir dire que l'arbitré autorité sur
les joueurs qu'ils soient meilleurs les
arbitres après que les enfants et ont
l'habitude de 2
de côtoyer des milieux sportifs bien
qu'ils prennent l'habitude de respecter
eux aussi leurs arbitres et puis une
autre interview à présent un autre
témoignage arbitres lui a un peu plus
d'expérience il exerce notamment du côté
des longs cours où nous l'avons
rencontré
et il estime que les arbitres ne doivent
pas se replier sur eux-mêmes écouter
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait voir
je pense qu'il faut il faut que les
arbitres que munich sont pas ils sont
pas dans leur bulle à faire ce qu'ils
ont à faire il faut aussi qu'ils
participent au jeu donc ça implique
aussi de la communication avec les
joueurs avec les éducateurs avec les
avec les assistants avec avec le public
et faire mieux connaître l'arbitrage et
pour continuer à évoquer ces journées de
l'arbitrage et la situation sur le
terrain je reçois présent brise marine
et bonsoir et bienvenue
bonsoir merci de nous avoir rejoints je
sais que n'a pas été forcément facile en
raison de la circulation
arbitre animateur de la section
formation dans le département des
yvelines
un peu plus tôt avant que vous
n'arriviez nous regardions un reportage
consacré à nicolas perrot vous
connaissez peut-être s'être énervé et
qui a rencontré des difficultés sur le
terrain puisqu'il a été victime d'une
agression
est-ce que son cas est un cas isolé ou
parce que c'est fréquent sur les
terrains ces difficultés rencontrées par
les arbitres c'est à gré alors voyez il
ya une haute autorité du football qui
est à mesurer et en gros il ya 97 % des
matchs qui se passe très bien
donc c'est une très grosse minorité
d'ailleurs nicolas est l'un des rares
mythes avoir été frappé dans les
yvelines et vous avez vécu vous même ce
genre de situation nos gars sont donc la
situation pouvait dégénérer
bon il ya eu des matches tendus j'avais
senti de situation là pouvant amener à
prendre un coup parce qu'on parle de
violence d'agression il n'y a pas que ça
il ya aussi des petites phrases tout au
long du match des attitudes widgets et
entière des incivilités om sommes tout à
fait ça fait ça fait partie des choses
qui arrivent mais globalement ça se
passe quand même plutôt bien localement
mais comment on peut l'expliquer que les
arbitres quelquefois ne soit pas
respecté ça c'est un une vaste question
après mons a fait ça fait bien sûr
partie peut-être d'une chose de plus
global d'une remise en cause de
l'autorité
et vraiment et surtout un problème
d'éducation après c'est assez compliqué
est-ce que vous pouvez intervenir vous
notamment vous êtes animateur d'une
section de formation dans le département
vous intervenez pour expliquer que mal
arbitre c'est un joueur aussi comme un
autre il faut aussi le respecter alors
bien sûr bien sûr on intervient déjà
auprès des éducateurs qui ont la
première qui sont les premières former
les jeunes dans le cadre de leur
processus de formation le district d
uriner est l'un des districts qui a
gardé en fait la capacité à former les
éducateurs avec une partie arbitrage et
donc de fait c'est plus c'est plus
facile pour nous de toucher ce public
qui est celui des éducateurs et
eurotrans peine derrière notre message
après on peut aussi se déplacer dans les
clubs ça a été le cas je sais que
l'année dernière je suis quelquefois
déplacer dans les clubs qui sont
d'ailleurs demandeur alors quand on
parle de ces violences dans le sport on
évoque souvent le cas du football global
football plus que dans les autres sports
ces journées nationales de l'arbitrage
on va quand même le rappeler il ya
plusieurs fédérations qui sont associés
de sports collectifs que ce soit le bas
c est que ce soit leur langue ou donc le
football mais en général on évoque
plutôt les violences envers les arbitres
dans le football par digérer que déjà le
football c'est le plus grand nombre de
licenciés en france est le sport le plus
populaire du moins le plus médiatisé et
donc bien sûr je pense que c'est plus
facilement relégable
maintenant il ya de cela deux semaines
et demie à deux heures bits de rugby qui
sont fait frapper enfin moins parler on
en a parlé dans l'état fait tout à fait
parce que il n'y a pas la même
couverture médiatique
le sport c'est le football est un sport
qui en tout cas suscite beaucoup de
passion et donc de fait une belle
couverture médiatique et au delà de ça
vous quand ça vous vous avez décidé de
vous engager dans l'arbitrage de devenir
arbitre vous n'êtes pas posé la question
du tout vous dire bah peut-être que
quelques fois ça peut être dangereux sur
un terrain une question de sécurité
aussi leur mariage on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure avec le reportage d' anthony
rech il était question de ses arbitres
aussi qu'ils abandonnent tout simplement
cette cette profession voire quelquefois
juste cette vocation parce qu'ils sont
chanceux aussi en amateur ils sont pas
forcément payé vois aucun moment
vous êtes dit que c'était peut-être trop
risqué non non vraiment qu'à un moment
je lui dis je me suis jamais sentie
vraiment menacée donc non non c c'est à
dire que les rares moments où j'ai dû je
pense que en huit ans d'arbitrage j'ai
dû avoir trois matches que j'ai regardé
ma montre en disant quand est ce que ça
se termine vous voyez et c'est des
moments juste parce que une certaine
tension qui font que bon le match et pas
spécialement agréable
je me suis jamais senti menacé vous
parlez du travail des éducateurs aussi
ça veut dire que quelques fois ils ne
font pas leur travail ils le tiennent
mal leurs jeunes quelquefois aussi dans
les clubs alors je pense que non je
pense qu'au contraire les éducateurs
font bien leur boulot ils sont sont déjà
de mieux en mieux formés
le point qui est qui est essentiel c'est
que il faut pas chercher à faire du nom
mais on va chercher à faire la qualité
dans le nombre d'éducateurs et là dessus
le district des yvelines joue bien son
rôle
car quelles sont les qualités des bons
arbitres aussi comme on en fait pour que
ça ne dégénère pas une situation où en
tout cas déjà pour bien arbitré un match
parce que vous n'êtes pas à l'abri d'une
erreur oui c'est une bonne question
quelle est bonne à invite le bon arbitre
c'est celui c'est celui qui fait
accepter ses erreurs je pense c'est ça
le bon arbitre c'est celui qui fait que
c'était ses décisions qu'elles soient
bonnes ou mauvaises et quelquefois il
faut gérer le public aussi parce qu'on
n'y a pas une bonne décision de prise le
public sait se faire entendre on entend
aussi souvent le public s'en prendre aux
arbitres alors le oui oui il ya le plus
bon le public les arbitres sont censés
en faire abstraction ce moment une
carapace qui se fait par un pont en
public mais c'est vrai que nature faut
gérer l'environnement quand on a un
public dans lequel on n'a pas honte des
bombes agricoles là l'arbitré doit
intervenir forcément mais mais c'est
rare en tout cas au niveau départemental
des yvelines c'est arrivé donc voila
mais en tout cas bien sûr le
l'environnement et à gérer tout à
l'heure nous avons donné la parole aux
téléspectateurs il réagissait à
justement cette question comment faire
respecter les arbitres vous n'étiez pas
encore présents sur ce plateau je
propose de réécouter ce micro trottoir
et puis vous pourrez réagir
juste après il ya souvent les erreurs
d'arbitrage dans le sport notamment dans
le foot et c'est pour ça - pour moi il
devrait instaurer la vidéo et sinon en
général à part le foot l'arbitré
générale est plutôt bien son taf
si on prend des joueurs en guise
d'arbitré que ça il y aura plus de
respect qui est moins d'argent dans le
sport et j'en serai moins agressif jouer
pour le jeu et pas pour l'argent pour
éduquer les joueurs de l'entraînement
dès le plus jeune âge pour moi voilà
mais qui commence d'entraînement dans un
club pro bah faut leur dire que les
arbitres a autorité sur les joueurs là
qu'ils soient meilleurs les arbitres
rappelé que les enfants et ont
l'habitude de côtoyer des milieux
sportifs bien qu'ils prennent l'habitude
de respecter eux aussi leurs arbitres
pour que les arbitres soient meilleurs
même les parents s'y met mais ouais mais
qui viennent prône ainsi faut il donner
quelques coups aussi ça fait partie ça
fait partie des choses à enseigner de
demander aussi aux parents quelques fois
de devenir aussi joué le jeu et devenir
dans les clubs de sport de voir comment
ça se passe et et de venir sur la
pelouse
alors ouais ouais les parents souvent
pour les petites catégories les envolées
mais ce qu'on appelait avant les
débutants
les parents sont très présents
puisqu'ils suivent veulent voir leurs
petits jouets eux
deux fois ça se passe très bien des fois
ça se passe pas bien on a des banques
parfois des plus jeune âge des plus
jeune âge c'est troublant bon ça fait
partie
ça fait partie de cet environnement
maintenant bon faut ça reste à
relativiser globalement ça se passe
vraiment plutôt bien je pense aux
arbitres et en cfa à l'enrichir des
assises à laon pour ligne de paris donc
j'ai voulu en dh en cfa pour s'effacer
la troisième division derrière la 4e à
la ivème où il s'est fait oublier une
division au delà de rues de lhassa avec
ses arbitrages là on parle aussi de la
question de la vidéo pour les
professionnels est ce que ça changerait
quelque chose parce qu'on ne peut pas la
généraliser à l'ensemble des catégories
en cfa par exemple c'est pas possible
oui bien sûr bon il ya plusieurs thèmes
qui vont contre la vidéo
et plusieurs gens qui sont pour bon je
rentrais pas dans ce débat vous attend
pour moi à titre personnel je suis
plutôt contre pour univers raison mais
bon déjà il ya quand même le principe de
l'université du football et des lois du
jeu donc de fait les lois doivent être
les mêmes à chambourcy et quelle leçon à
marseille
enfin l'om donc donc de fait ça pose un
problème la vidéo là dessus une raison
pour laquelle vous êtes contre allée en
place de la vidéo parce que par moments
larbitre peut être amené à prendre une
décision qui ce qu'on appelle le pouvoir
discrétionnaire qui pour calmer le jeu
pour
voilà pour calmer les joueurs à un hiver
à faire baisser la tension peut faire
exprès de tromper pour donner voilà une
sanction qui va calmer une décision donc
il ya calmer tout le monde
et de fait la vidéo m est vraiment ça en
exergue et c'est à mon avis ça mollit
pas une bonne chose il faut laisser de
l'humain faut faut laisser l'humain et
tout ça et c'est l'essai de l'humain et
que chacun puisse s'entendre avec les
arbitres aussi merci à vous merci d'être
venu sur ce plateau et je rappelle un
serpent a été forcément évident à la
ronde céderait désir nous avoir rejoints
raison de la circulation
je rappelle que les journées de
l'arbitrage c'est en tout cas jusqu'au 3
novembre pour sensibiliser les joueurs
éviter aussi des agressions parfois être
dramatique c'est la fin de ce journal
pas de nouvelle édition demain je
retrouve lundi en direct à 18h en
revanche vous avez rendez vous dès
vendredi avec catherine plateau pour le
7-8 week end consacré à vos loisirs
excellente soirée sur téléfilm